if you've seen this show before you know
I get really heated for a hack
specifically cleaning hacks which is why
I'm so excited to welcome back to the
show Julian Thomas AKA Martha Stewart
that's right you got a marfat
like Martha
yeah that would be Brooklyn with it like
Martha you know Martha how did you come
up with that name so my friends actually
gave it to me uh I really love to throw
House parties and dinner parties and I
live in Brooklyn so my friends would
always call me Martha Stewart but
because it's Brooklyn they have that
little swag to it so it becomes Martha
Stewart like what up marf what about
Marfa so it just stuck so Julian we have
some cleaning hacks here that are
popular on Tic Tac Tick Tock right now
um will you take us through them
absolutely so the first one happens to
be uh my personal favorite and it is
drill brush attachments so these are
typically seen in car detailing but they
do wonders around the home uh especially
for uh tough stuck on dirt and grime so
I just
yes so as you can see uh they are
available in multiple colors because
this is really good uh because you can
designate one color for a specific area
of the home do I get to do this
absolutely we both get to do it so
you're going to want to like saturate
I'm like a greyhound at the gate right
so this is just water but typically I
was gonna say what should go in the
bottle
um any like your you know preferred
cleaning solution this is just water but
uh if whatever you do spray I highly
recommend you let it sit on the surface
for a little bit just to let it so
that's a fun tip yeah because then you
don't have a scrub as hard you know but
then when you are ready to start to do
exactly what you're doing
just go in wait a minute yeah right oh
my God oh my God
oh my God oh my God
it's so good and then you just take a
towel and you wipe it clean
I'm sorry I'm really sorry to selfishly
do this
yeah you have to I love it okay sorry
I got you
feel good right oh my God I mean
don't you feel better do you feel
cleansing in ways I can't even express I
love to hear it all right so next we
have a dusting situation so I hate
dusting with uh glass cleaner and paper
towel because paper towel will leave
behind like a residue and Little Fibers
yes and it's like what's the point of
dusting I couldn't agree more after
you've cleaned it I'm like it looks
dirtier right and so typically I always
recommend I recommend a microfiber cloth
but let's say they're dirty and they're
in the wash or you don't have any on
hand a really good alternative when
you're on the pinch is a coffee filter
can I spray it why not go ahead
boom so one thing I do Drew is actually
I will fold it in half
or maybe even in quarters that way
creates like a straight edge and it
makes it a little easier to Glide you
can really get into those like Corners
yeah and then you can just drag it
across and it makes a little bit easier
to get it into those Corners this is
really good for
Electronics espresso keyboards
so there you go
ah
really like you feel even better right
just this is going to be my new approach
there you go this is
are you a big coffee drinker
I'm not a coffee drinker but in my house
we have a coffee maker because everybody
else if they drink coffee so I'll just
use their food yeah as long as you have
it on hand so
um this pet hair yeah not it's a pet
hair remover right so it's a sustainable
alternative to Sticky sheet lint rollers
right because with the sticky sheet lint
roller you're just gonna toss it in the
trash and that's not good for the
environment so with this you can reuse
it over and over again all you do is
just drag it across your fabric surface
whether that's carpet rug clothes or
Upholstery and it picks up lint and pet
hair oh Lucy and Dougie you guys better
watch out see look at that and it just
captures on the blade
and I love the fact that it's like
lightweight and portable so you can toss
it in your bag leave it in your car
leave it at your desk so you can always
stay so fresh and so clean
that's crazy yeah oh my gosh okay
yeah there you go what's our last hack
actually I there is one more hack that I
was hoping you can actually help me with
uh so I hear you're a master at stains
and I am in desperate need of getting
stains out of my baseball caps
oh oh yeah do you get like a little
frontal sweater it's a little
embarrassing but hopefully you can help
me with that no it's not
it's nothing in fact all of my baseball
hats have a little bit of dirt in them
too because if I wear sunscreen it gets
in there and all my hats have it too so
it's not abnormal right good all right
now I don't feel bad
wait hold on
[Applause]
[Music]